[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cast a dit il est déjà en mode vacances
qu'il a mis des lunettes de soleil
c'est juste je vous le dis parce que
c'est castaldi il s'est fait refaire les
yeux il a des news de ou est-ce qu'on
peut montrer ce que ça sera quoi c'est
chaud ça fait peur vraiment ça fait pas
bon à la photo des bâtards je me permets
d'intervenir en fait l'histoire c'est
que nico m'a téléphoné mon meilleur ami
voilà avec nico avec ailleurs la nuit
voilà à cannes nico m'appelle me dire au
luxembourg ça m'ennuie de laisser loana
tout seul est ce que tu peux la
récupérer chez toi j'ai dit oui a pas de
problème elle bien la maison une chambre
d'amis aucun problème sauf que nico mas
pangée le coronavirus ben amer donc j'ai
dit ah oui et luan à ben je pense
qu'elle va la voir aussi avec ma maman
qui a 92 ans d'ailleurs je te souhaite
un joyeux anniversaire maman parce que
c'est comme ça gratuitement
mary mary bybowl embrasse mari voilà
donc c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui
comme ella âgée j'ai dit à loana je suis
désolé mais moi je prends pas de risques
la mer sur le corps à la verrue cgpi
cache une tombe
vendredi soir vers 20 heures je me suis
permis d'aller voir mais alors j'ai
frappé d'accord ouais donc je me suis
permis d'ouvrir et je les ai trouvé
allongé sur le canapé lit la bouche
ouverte
[Musique]
dénudée presque donc je vais lucas
respirer j'ai toujours appelé les
pompiers
ils m'ont dit vous pouvez la mettre sur
le côté j'ai écouté à l'alcool il
je vois qu'elle respire donc l est pas
c'est ça le respire donc ça va mais je
me vois pas trop la touche et on peut y
aller pas billets
[Musique]
le dernier jour quand on devait tout de
même ramené sur nice le matin ils
étaient venus dans la chambre et
s'allonger à côté de moi je dis mais
qu'est ce que tu fais après ma 1000e son
doigt sur son mât bush est la sienne
monde de m'embrasser
donc moi je les repousser et je dîne en
question désolé mais vos cultures me
ramène chez moi de suite et je peux
jamais qu'on se parle de toi et moi elle
a eu la leur et donc après il ay la
purée n'diaye de l'indus qu'à nice
aucun mot incroyable alors chris anker
sanaa avait un pseudo sur les réseaux
sociaux il se faisait appeler justin
ferrand en fait avec ce pseudo il
contacte des jeunes femmes souvent
mineurs il leur demandait des photos
d'elle dénudée fossard que la clarisse
en question c'est une jeune femme qui
est autiste donc c'est important de
savoir si christian quesada cibler des
victimes faibles faible
psychologiquement ce que j'aime aussi
est venu me parler et en fait elle est
venue jusqu'à l'autel donc pour
rencontrer christian et il lui a fait du
chantage
il a dit si tu viens pas avec tu
rencontreras pas si rennes est en vrai
allawi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
moi j'ai pris les matelas avec l'aide
il n'est pas la noce sur dix mois un
macho et j'embrasse annoncé un assaut
ciblant la descente des madoff chez lui
à la fois avec aussi deux personnes mais
comparé leur carte de séjour ici
bencheikh et kaka humaine à l'horizon
moins que si que voilà du coup bas comme
vous voyez sur les vidéos ben ça pas
réfléchir s'enchaîner j'avais paniquer
ou pas avait paniqué vous êtes il faut
qu'on les sent franchement on
réfléchissait pas on a foncé
on a mobilisé les jeunes on s'est
entraidés et dans un quartier politique
comme ça je sais moi déchets très beau
sexy et on est vraiment dans les même si
c'est un quartier prioritaire
aujourd'hui moi j'ai partagé cette vidéo
justement avec océane aussi que je salue
puisque c'est un peu grâce à elle qu'on
a eu aussi cette vidéo pour justement
faire valoir parce que le soir même on a
vu que les pompiers enfin 20 minutes
avait marqué que les pompiers étaient
venus éteindre le feu mais on n'avait
pas dit que c'étaient les jeunes qui ont
pu aussi vécu ça comme des agressions
j'ai vécu ça comme j'ai chanté la dette
sociale ou pressés à des moments dans
votre carrière pourtant le mec vous
pointe dans les toilettes we come here a
conclu que c'est quoi cette histoire est
badgée vous êtes dans les toilettes avec
mini tu ne sortiras pas des toilettes
tant que tu ne m'auras pas fine gâteries
quoi voilà c'était quoi ça à la radio et
les ratios c'était avec non c'était
quand j'étais à vsd
aucun journal veilleuse les mecs avec ma
direction nommée quoi il ya un mec qui
est venu à toi lewis était votre
hiérarchie comme un suivi dans les
toilettes non non non c'était un ami une
personnalité de l'extérieur et qui
rentrait derrière moi et qui m'a dit bon
ben voilà maintenant il va falloir c'est
quelqu'un de connu et loire est gentil
oui c'était quelqu'un de connu voilà qui
vous suivent aux toilettes qui m'a suivi
aux toilettes et qui me fait dire que
l'an passé sont rigolos barratier
rentrer dans des toilettes avec moi et
quand je suis sorti d'une voilette ils
étaient deux dans la forme de ma vie
mais maintenant il va falloir
falloir pour vous en être sorti 10 j'ai
dit oh ben ça va pas être possible là
parce que si je me mets criaient on aura
l'air de compte tous les deux mais à
l'arrivée c'est moi qu'on va aider et
vous m'avez jamais parler après non je
moi je n'ai jamais parlé de toutes les
agressions que j'ai subi mais je trouve
que c'est particulièrement mesquin
honnêtement d'aller dénigrer une
émission qui plus est dans une émission
rival qui a exactement le un talk show
et je trouve que ça ne se fait pas tout
bêtement alors leur vitesse et sa
filiale lendemain pour qu'ils viennent
voilà ici
il a même pas répondu sachez le bon
c'est vrai que patrick timsit et le
courage ça fait deux ans mais ça le plus
le plus triste c'est que ça n'est pas
être le mec il à perdre là il est venu
le savait et moi je vous dit tout j'ai
envoyé cette année alors je lui envoyais
d'abord deux points d'interrogation
après julie il a l'air super drôle ton
spectacle je suis plutôt sympa un frère
ça fait 20 ans que des plus drôles
précieux profitent pour retravailler
frérot ça te détruit des neurones c'est
insultant pour notre public et ça je
laisserai pas passer là il m'a répondu
je ne connaissais pas ton numéro tu sais
c'est de la vanne tu vas giovan
ce n'est pas plus grave que ça bonne
soirée à toi oui tu t'inquiètes zéro
souci je ferai une réponse drôle aussi
et après aimé des émaux ji qui ne doit
pas comprendre ferrat ont pourrait
expliquer tous les deux et du vol pour
les millions je viens européens 4
ménagez pas besoin de faire un 400 m en
vais pas me faire inquiète nous avons
croisé un jour patrick on va nous dire
tout ce qu'il fait c'est pas drôle
la seule phrase que j'aime passer de
trucs sur ma famille ça mon petit gars
ça passera pas voilà c'est bien ce ne
sera pas seulement je vois pas ces
dépouilles l'abruti les fermes ta gueule
sk volta non j'aime pas j'aime pas
énervé j'aime pas j'aime pas voilà ça me
rappelle ce qu'on guillon la kabylie a
même chose
calmez vous benjamins non mais là alors
patrick autant braastad j'embrasse pas
du tout enfin en attendant la fin
d'ailleurs non non je t'emmerde
et là mais je suis désolé c'est hyper
irrespectueux vis-à-vis de benjamin
genêt riz peut pas dire que benjamin
écrit un livre sur ses grands parents
qui l'aiment d'amour juste pour faire
doubler je veux dire à mon avis la
baisse de ce soit et s'est révélé tel
qu'il est surmontée
méchant et pas drôle mais c'est pas là
oh là là qu occupe toi de ton festival
nava pape sera plus que ça à [ __ ]
allez vas-y vous aimez bien patrick remy
non je déteste et vous avez bien gérald
beaulieu canon général de tadamoun mercy
madonna et on remettra ça passe merci
gérad ancêtres ça transpirait mi-séance
à deux soirs à tous et merci d'être avec
nous d'être en direct alors je vous le
dis enfin petit anniversaire aujourd'hui
c'est un mini anniversaire pourquoi
parce que on l'a vu dans les archives on
l'a vu dans l'émission de benjamin
castaldi
ce qui nous manque le plus c'est le
lévitique le public donc beaucoup à
cette émission vous nous manquer
énormément les cherry et on a hâte de
vous retrouver et sachez le si il ya
possibilité qu'on se retrouve avant la
fin de la saison on fera un énorme prime
avec du public avec des dark à avec des
bus avec des duplex avec une grosse
somme à la fin on le fera avec vous mes
chéris ouais on fait ce rapport rade
plateau c'est une expression avec
l'arabe
ça c'est dingue ça s'est décidé à vous
ça annoncez vos idées à vous c'est pas
mon vrai nom est évoqué c'est quand même
extraordinaire c'est que je ne en fait
je ne suis jamais autant animalisés que
par les progressistes comme vous vous
avez votre ami bela tarr qui m'avait
traité de chameau kenya genre messia
vous êtes le françois pignon de la
télévision et de la pelle comme c'est à
dire le grand dîner de cons et vous êtes
vous vous êtes le grand flou
vous êtes le grand clown de la télé
parce que vous avez passé saison sur tf1
nous en était jeté comme un malpropre
c'est vrai vous allez vous après et
après vous après vous être fait des
heureux en or use est surtout les toutes
les personnes celles avec lesquelles
vous avez d un conte ans et peut-être
des amitiés alors j'en ai bonne amitié
je serais vous je viens de rappeler je
viendrai pas trop la ramener sur ce
terrain bourru lice vous avez voulu
soutirer des infos et oui oui à qui j'ai
su tirer désormais vous êtes malade on
sait la vérité ou d'arrêter mais hélas
combien de fois j'ai une longue et rien
n'est jamais payé assez vite j'y crois
pas trop
déjà on n'a pas idée au gâchis des os et
le premier rappelle aussi ce que vous
appeler comme ça ok et je trouve pas ça
drôle se déformer nous qu'il faut
respecter
voilà toutes les personnes et d'ailleurs
et la merguez et demandent des prix à 4
[Musique]
patrice la production est happé pyramide
et moi même que brigitte désolé vous
avez des forums
vous avez voulu serein beurre mais vous
aime a choisi quoi vous avez pris entre
guillemets pour qu'on comprenne ce que
je dis là seul black à la télé qu'il n'a
pas vécu ça je sais sûrement qu'ils ont
vécu mais moi je ne vais pas vêtu
viennent au contraire on était entre
nous on en rigolait en rigolait public
du coup le public a évolué on avait des
jeunes des quarantenaires des dieux tout
le monde et cela je suis même de moments
je me déguisais et où on s'éclate et
pour moi c'était une cour de récréation
vue c'est des jeux qui m'ont touché
profondément dans mon coeur gilles
verdez pétards reste avec mon fils
gilles verdez vous jugez vous avez été
choqué plane entendu comme plein de gens
parlent assez camby et quand vous
entendez pepita aujourd'hui qui se dit
elle kiki et qui aujourd'hui harceler
qui est en fait on a fait tomber son
rêve
on a fait tomber tout ce qu'elle avait
dans la tête d'où les rêves qu'elle
avait appelé tous les souvenirs
ils sont tombés à cause de cette
émission que vous lui répondez est
exactement et je vais faire ce que je
fais rarement celle de oui je vais
passer vraiment parce que quand on
entend pépites à l'émission de tmc a
complètement détourné les images les a
sortis de leurs gonds
texte c'est presque un mensonge